hey reject nation happy Sunday to all of
you guys over at our patreon one of the
reward tiers that we have whatever video
you request we must definitely do Rosa
para one of our longtime pledges and
also one of our highest patrons ever has
always requests something that is not a
reaction and we create Lea preciate that
because you believe we can do more than
just that she loves it when we talk
about movie news we actually do enjoy
talking about movie news we're gonna
talk about some movie news of the week
for you all don't got some affinity war
stuff here and then a couple of other
things that are not infinity war haha
anyway let's get to the top stories of
the week guys
everyone is apparently surprised by
Avengers infinity wars
presales beating out any presale record
set for superhero films you woulda thunk
it what that the culmination of all MCU
films would come on guys obviously it's
going to what's interesting is here they
have a Fandango survey of more than a
thousand movie goers which is about how
many people go to the movies every year
every year only a thousand people go
it's really sad actually everyone's
waiting great to go on Netflix 97% can't
wait to see how dozens of heroes work
together in the same film three percent
could care less ninety-four percent are
excited to see different franchise
characters guardians Avengers etc you
know the group etc oh yeah I'm a meeting
one another for the first time six
percent are like who gives a damn I wish
it was just one event one avenger 92
percent see infinity war as the
culmination of all the MCU films before
it eight percent believe this is
subjective objective 87 percent have
seen all the MCU movies thirteen percent
of the people who did not be watching
infinity for 71 percent black panther on
the big screen twenty nine percent a
racist 60 percent claim black panther
made them even more excited to see
Avengers infinity war it's probably the
only percentage one that I
actually think is interesting when the
infinity war trailer came out before
Black Panther even released in the
theaters they showed that there was
gonna be a fight in Wakanda when
everyone was like we're kinda like a
hidden place but everyone's here right
now but the way Black Panther ends it
opens up the door T's in a way like if
you remember the trailers oh yeah no but
how makes sense what we have this big
fight going on in infinity war timing
it's perfect timing
it's perfect timing and with the record
sales that Black Panther has hit 60
percent feel more excited now for
infinity war that's cool I'm glad people
are gonna show for more than just Tony
Stark and yeah Haider man they're gonna
be going for the BP man that's
heartening now a lot of people seem very
excited that T'Challa is in this and you
know that lion the trailer I hear people
quoting all the time get this man a
shield yeah yeah somebody get these men
is shield it's pretty good oh really
it's alright oh it's getting better guys
story number two goes like this
spielberg hates anything that streams
that's it let's move on story number
three we are of course making jokes Jon
humor Spielberg basically of what every
headline has been reading as for this
guy Netflix movie specifically he
shouldn't be eligible for Oscars let's
see what he actually says first
television is greater today than it has
ever been in the history of television I
don't agree with that I Love Lucy best
cereal show ever
there's been writing better directing
better performances and better stories
being told however the director went on
to say that even though a television is
a thriving medium it poses a clear and
present danger to film goers clear nor
present danger Jack Ryan starring
Harrison Ford in fact once you commit to
a television format you're a TV movie
which is a great point because it's what
all TV shows that are dramas or serials
have become a good show deserves an Emmy
but not an Oscar I don't believe that
films were just given token
qualifications and a couple of feeders
for less than a week should qualify for
the Academy Award nomination well spill
Berg I'm sure you haven't had a hard
time in the past like 40 to 50 years
getting a damn
moving in the feeders I mean and what is
television now anyway I mean like even
the idea of television television is
more of a device like literal device you
never like used to think television and
go oh yeah shows now you think
television and go oh yeah my TV that
thing that I occasionally watch things
on I'm wondering how many directors who
are like above the age of let's say 45
and up agree with this statement you
know because nowadays everyone knows
that to get a movie in the theaters and
to get recognition is harder than it's
ever been and that's where the idea of
independent filmmaking and movie is made
for TV platforms like Netflix like
Amazon like Hulu I've been able to bring
like good quality movie Magel Netflix
and I think I missed the mark we're just
sitting there in the Oscars when my band
was nominated going mean like I feel
like if we want to get down to brass
tacks it's a movie it's a contained
story within two hours it doesn't matter
where you exist like yes technically it
wasn't in the theater you got a screen
in a theater on a couple of screens and
sure there are things to argue about
within that I just don't think they're
that important to the actual debate if
it's a Lifetime movie or like a TNT
movie or something like that I guess
maybe there's an argument a distinction
there but like Netflix a place that you
know for movies before you knew it for
TV shows if they release a movie on
there and they've even talked about I
don't know what the legitimacy of this
is but like having their own theater for
stuff they acquires
or even looking in a movie like oak jar
or something like that I feel like that
that's a movie or it's not a TV show I'm
hearing about Scorsese is biopic
Irishman with like the greats the
Italian answers all coming together that
sounds like something that could be
oscar-worthy cuz Netflix isn't TV like
it's just it's just a video store the
bottom line Spielberg film medium has
changed it's changed you are still one
of the greatest directors
all time and many will hail you as the
greatest director of all time don't be
upset it's ok Spielberg
I do feel them they're like I want the
theatrical experience to be there yeah I
feel you in a sense like I get the
exhibition and the large format isn't I
value that but I don't understand why
we're like these Netflix movies
shouldn't get Oscars I'm like who cares
cares is fine give it a like not even
ready player one a trance yeah I know
he's not actually as whiny he's just
saying an opinion I'm just I'm sure
Johnny
guys James Gunn has apparently seen
infinity war and he has tweeted that it
is the worst Marvel movie to have ever
come out this comes as a shock to
everyone yeah I like that the headline
is you'll never believe what he said and
then this is exactly what I thought you
liked Marvel would be cool with him
being like guys skip infinity got some
serious notes for the Avengers infinity
war is incredible Wow and that's all
I'll say for the time being hashtag
event yeah you know the hashtag I tried
water hashtag it was wet people are
loving James Gunn's confirmation of this
and to me I think there's some
credibility to be said in certain
retrospect because James Gunn does not
go out of his way for every Marvel film
to say if he loves it or not and if he
does love it he'll put it out there so
there's some credibility to his name and
he's not shy of opening up his criticism
I know Marvel will probably limit him on
what he can criticize you know see you
only positive feedback before releases
yeah I mean yeah even though the
employer even tell people in private
screenings you can only say positive
things most of the time before you
actually go out there and give a full
review the embargo is for harder
opinions yeah but this is no surprise at
all people are apparently like oh they
God but of course he's gonna say that
course you gonna I'm sure every director
of all the MCU is gonna go out there
it's a well and and I mean in my mind I
entertain that thought of like well yeah
your your marvel - this doesn't really
mean that much to me like I like James
Gunn generally I think he usually speaks
his mind in a way that's alright James
and doesn't seem like a biased guy but
you gotta take this with a little bit of
a grain of salt yeah yeah I agree it's
gonna suck guys and totally we feel that
Sony Pictures is gearing up for its men
and black reboot thingy that they're
doing which is we all want that and it's
being directed by F gary Gray who has
dusk films like law-abiding citizen
mhmmm Straight Outta Compton the Italian
the Italian Job be cool cool classic
classic way better than get shorty fate
of the Furious fate of the fury oh
that's the best in the series those guys
he's got all the things you apparently
here's what they're looking a cast for
this and I think this casting decision
is a good halfway point where everyone's
dream casting ideas have come from
because you could just go with white guy
and a black guy again you know or you
could go the all-female route and piss
off the world but they're meeting a good
medium here I think and the casting
choice actually makes sense to me here
hearing who they have in mind I think to
myself that sounds like it could be
really entertaining actually they're
thinking of going with Chris Hemsworth
and Tessa Thompson Chris Hemsworth who
you know from that war movie that came
out this year everyone saw in January
and Tessa Thompson who starred in the
hit blockbuster overseas annihilation no
it's not it's not a real movies on
Netflix it's on Netflix Chris Hemsworth
Tessa Thompson
they had great chemistry and thor
ragnarok they were both really funny
really cool they can both play tough
characters and yeah exactly they both
can run there I think there are a
perfect casting choice for reboot cuz
you can't just redo old white guy and
young hotshot black guy Will Smith you
got to do a complete different casting
choice and you got to find that right
medium and I think this is a perfect
medium for a movie goer like myself I
heard this guy
or something yeah these guys are both
funny and they're both badass
they were just in thor ragnarok which is
like a sci-fi comedy this is perfect I
feel like the way to get us really
excited about continuing men and black
is to get us really excited about the
leads again because it's the leads that
get you excited about the men in black
world to be honest I mean it's a cool
world but the thing that you take away
from the stretch of the first one is the
second two movies the other stuff is
cool but you have to have your
characters be on point and some of that
falls on the writing for sure especially
if we're gonna keep this going and make
it fresh I think these guys are a great
choice and it's like nice to see this at
like the start of Chris Hemsworth real
big crest into more hammers material
more comedy and as I don't care how you
feel about the Ghostbusters reboot I
still think he was hilarious in that
film
oh yes and still hilarious and thor
ragnarok so this is this is ideal
casting I'm not sure you can say this is
this is perfect to me guys our last
story ending on an infinity war thingy
you see how we did that infinity war
spill bird infinity war
men in black but it's still kind of
Avenger II cuz it's Chris Hemsworth Reap
ESA's of infinity bread with Chris Evans
is reportedly going out there saying
once more that he's not gonna be Captain
America anymore
The Times profile goes on to say for now
he has no plans to return to the
franchise here's what he said you want
to get off the train before they push
you off he's quoting snowpiercer
[Laughter]
marketing marketing one of his many
films that people did not see too so
people like people like five people well
some people like Chris Evans movies that
don't make my yeah one thing's for sure
he's gonna not die in infinity war
because he says here too that he has
planned reshoots in the fall for the 4th
it's good luck
I would love it if he did die in
infinity warren and then in the fourth
movie he just comes back as a bunch more
of those little psays from spider-man
I'm this kind of makes me wonder like
what if they're just having people lie
like what if they are so they can
mislead all the fan theories and whatnot
so this makes you go oh well he's
definitely not gonna die infinity war
then it's definitely gonna be higher me
or maybe it's neither maybe they'll
they'll do all this teasing and then the
end of the fourth movie they'll reveal
we saw these guys for example right well
it kind of makes sense with the
trajectory of how MCU movies have been
going and the fan theory doesn't seem
far off that he would die then Bucky
would take up the mantle in terms of how
the comic books line up and we've been
learning to like Bucky a lot more lately
this all makes sense for him to leave
out of all the actors who have been
signed on to MCU world Chris Evans has
seemed like the one who just kind of
wants out you know yeah and I've heard
the the talk that he wants to go and
direct more and things like that sure he
would like to get some different kind of
acting roles again because the guy's a
super talented actor man he's the only
good thing in Fantastic Four he's in a
lot of other dramas too he was even in
that Ice Man movie with Michael Shannon
and he had a really good role in that
too
this guy's a great actor and he has a
lot more range than buff white dude yeah
yeah you do drama and he could do comedy
as well and cap is honestly there's a
great like central character but he's
not the most interesting character and
for someone with the caliber of talent
that Chris Evans has you have I could
see why you would want to leave it's
kind of been vocal about wanting to get
out even we signed on a new Captain
America he was he was like I'm pretty
skeptical about being a part of this
from the very beginning he's been that
way so it doesn't shock me at all who
wants to go I'm sure there's a bummer
for some people but I think in some ways
this could be an exciting term for the
franchise too I like him as Captain
America and I generally like that
franchise kind of toward the top of
their various franchises for a number of
reasons but I kind of would like to see
it move on to some juicier roles some
different kinds of things
it gives also a certain sense of stakes
that not everyone's going to be
forever it gives it a finality and I
think that's appropriate he's gonna
leave his mark and move on and pass the
torch to somebody else and cap I mean
where we left him off it seems like he's
not really identifying with the world
yeah he's honored ID as the oldest
virgin in the world that's the real
issue that's the real issue I want that
to be his last line I'm gonna die
version or you'll American who never got
married
well guys those are the top stories of
the week
Rosa Parra my dear I know you just got
back from Boston you were out there for
a convention to take your daughter your
beautiful daughter Cassandra
to some stuff that you could care less
about but it's not know that you were
there is you're a great mom and that's
the kind of world that we need to live
in a world of great mothers no this
abusive [ __ ] needs us just stop there
all you abusive mothers you watch this
channel you need be more like Parra stop
abusing and take your kids to
conventions you don't want to go to
sacrifices for the ones you look up the
next Teen Titans go one and check it out
and Rosa we love you my dear and I
ordered you a gift but I don't think
it's been shipped here so I think we're
just gonna send you something smaller
but nicer because we love you guys you
can subscribe to the real rejects it's a
YouTube channel and you can click the
YouTube notification bell here just like
you have for a bunch of other channels
that you ignore check us out on patreon
we do weekly Q&A is we take a question
from a patron and do a full video
response to it we don't just breeze
through your questions make a two-hour
film two-hour film based on it only on
patreon and we can't get nominated for
Oscars but we can't get nominated for
Emmy and full-length TV show reactions
over there as well a lot of good stuff
love to have you happy Sunday appreciate
God and spend time with your family like
I do once in awhile take care guys